i hate to bring him up again but logan
paul is for some reason he's
so good at like not being ahead of
trends but being the first one
just behind the trend you know what i'm
saying like he's really good at like
taking action
right as something is becoming popular
like pokemon whatever he's years behind
this [ __ ]
like marcus was marcus was working on an
nft company two years ago
that's when all these companies wearable
like i'm pretty sure that's when they
all
were uh created was like in the first
crypto boom
and but logan paul is really good so he
made his he
partnered with this company he made his
own nft which is basically just a
card with like some really shitty like
it looked like they hired a twitter fan
to make that art
on the front of the card right i mean
it's not
i mean it i mean it was like a joke
first for like a 2
000 card that's what he was selling them
for the art was like
pretty basic yeah like you could hire
you could hire someone to do that for
twenty dollars
yeah and so he he sells
he's made five million dollars off these
things already right he sold like
and they were kind of linked to like
like if you buy one of these cards then
you're in a raffle to get one of the
pokemon
things that he got like the pokemon sets
or whatever that he's been selling
no that's not it no no
it looks different
[Music]
that's that's i think a fan render or
something like that that's sick
yeah no uh i definitely wanna look it up
on open
open c open c dot io luke so i'm okay so
i'm looking it up so he sells like a
couple thousand of these things right
makes five million dollars
just so i'm curious a cool 5 million
so i was curious like you know
about how much of a bubble this is this
really is right now and i'm looking up
like trade volume because like that's
one of the things top shot
is the is the top nft thing right now
based on trade volume because there's so
many people buying these things and
trading them
yeah after the fact which lets you know
that people like
feel like there's value to these things
right it's like i want that here's mine
i want to buy that one i want to sell
this one
but logan paul there's like sales volume
was like 100 grand or something like
that
in the last week or something like that
or maybe 24 hours but
on 5 million dollars worth of cards sold
which means most people are just
buying them and then not doing anything
with them which is
that's the worst part of it is like he's
just
just taxing people like it doesn't
actually use the technology you know
what i'm saying
yeah i mean there's on one hand there's
these systems
marketplaces and that's why top chat is
so cool it's like an all-in-one
god and cause yeah pull it up real fast
this is the custom card
no
oh that's what he
okay well it looks i mean the art looked
totally different on the
on the website on the actual marketplace
where you could buy them oh
man it wasn't that
those are cool though i definitely want
to pay for that go to open c and just
search logan paul
and like it's like a little anime
version of logan paul
imagine paying for a hentai
image of logan paul yeah
i'm pretty sure those are free somewhere
this well okay so
yeah okay so there's this like world
where top shot
exists which is is cool because
the cards are like incredible there are
like little animated
replays of some of the best sports
moments and then
you can see you know there's like
different holographic
versions of everything you can see a
serial number so you know like which one
you have
the lower the serial number the higher
value it is yeah
and then you can there's like a built-in
marketplace so you can sell and
buy from people and like all the other
nft
um stuff like uh there's like
you know digital versions of like games
like match
magic the gathering and stuff where you
can buy these cards and you can
play with each other and stuff like that
but
the logan paul thing is just this
one-off
collector's i guess it's basically like
an art piece right
it's like wearable or whatever you can
buy nft art where it's just one of a
kind
here i'm selling this it's one of one
or one of 2 000 buy it if you want and
then you can sell it later on like a
on a market place like open seat but
it's like
who's the market no i don't think
there's any i don't know what'd you say
it's like who's the market for that
that's what i'm saying that's at that
point
i want the card that's why i say that's
the worst part about it is like it
sounds like he's doing something that's
really modern and really forward but
he's not he's just selling a [ __ ]
hoodie
it's the same thing yeah like his fans
just buy the [ __ ] and they're like
now i have the nft logan paul card and
if they put that out on
it's a little it's a little scammy it
feels like a scam to me because
i mean i like i looked at it for a long
time because i was like is this
something like nft art
where i i'm gonna buy this and hang on
to it and then i'm gonna glad
i'm glad i like you know own the
ownership to this thing
you know what i'm saying but like all
the nft art that you that's being traded
on
websites like wearable are really
[ __ ] cool like the artist puts a lot
of time into it
yeah i mean some artists i follow
started doing like ai generated art and
it was like super interesting
um and even that ai
nude image that i referenced before i
don't i don't know if luke had brought
an example of that but there's like a
couple of these like nude abstract
paintings that were done with like ai
they're actually super dope and i think
they're dope because
they're clearly generated from like a
specific mix oh
thank you of you know obviously nude
images and it creates like this
truly like probably a one-of-a-kind
production and you're like [ __ ]
that actually is pretty sweet and i can
conceptually understand why you'd want
to have that
um i cannot understand why you would
just
pay for this nft art that really a lot
of people have
and no one will actually ever want i
cannot imagine ever
putting out logan and if logan paul nft
and anyone
like i need there there is a chance in
like 10 years
that people are gonna be like wait did
you get that logan paul card the only
one he ever made
yeah because i mean it's like kind of
there are real life equivalents to that
too
it's like so and so company that made a
thousand of these things and they never
made it
ever again right it's totally totally
possible yeah but
i i don't think that's what they're
banking on i think it feels more like
let's just get in on this right now and
make a bunch of money
and then you know uh 2 000 people are
stuck with this
place on a blockchain that is actually
working worth nothing
but now i have five million dollars in
my account that's kind of what it feels
like to me
but maybe i'm maybe i'm wrong i like you
know this is this could be like
the opinion of someone two years ago
where they're like i don't understand
this who would ever pay for crypto art
and now like tons of people are yeah
luke did you find it the actual image
um i'm i'm still in the way of this is
just scamming
this is it right here like come on dude
come on son come on son
this is like one of those images that's
like logan i drew you what do you think
yeah are you joking that's what i'm
saying yeah
all right yeah logan paul made 3.5
million in one day
oh my god thousand dollars each and i
feel like the most
people that bought them are just like
all right let's see what happens like no
i'm just gonna buy it and it's just kind
of like
yeah total look at the reply there total
sales five million dollars
and the price was one ethereum huh
oh there's still four there's dude
there's still 414 left should we get in
on it
oh yeah
yo that art is free somewhere i know
that art is free somewhere
yeah so that's the thing that's like i
don't
i don't understand the value it's not
tied to anything besides this like weird
raffle he's doing for
men's pokemon packs it's not like tied
to anything in real life it's not
it doesn't have cool art there's no
community around it so i just don't
understand what the purpose of this was
but just to make fast money off this
[ __ ]
which dude people say you could say yeah
you're just angry you didn't make a
bunch of money off this but it's like
it doesn't feel like i don't know it
just doesn't feel like it's really
actually taking advantage of the
technology
it feels like it's trying to exploit it
like there's gonna be now with this nft
boom there's going to be
tons and tons of just junk yeah
people trying to make fast money and
this kind of feels to me like it's one
of those
well uh you know i
cannot imagine that this image uh
appreciates even in 10 years
but that's what i'm saying it's not
really about the image like they clearly
didn't actually give a [ __ ] about the
art
but isn't isn't that more about the i
own one of these logan paul cards
yeah but isn't that part of it though
like
you're you're paying for something that
like has
some value that doesn't just look like a
copy and paste of a
you know hearthstone card like i i don't
know
you know maybe i'm wrong maybe i don't
know what the hell i'm talking about i
just can't see how
i'm just trying to say like when i when
i look at other nft things like what
you're talking about like with nba
topshop
you're you're owning something unique it
has like a certain value that's
like inter you know i guess
intrinsic or like you know you look at
it and you're like wow this is this is
special look at this i'm proud i own
this
and maybe people get that from logan
paul cards but i just don't see how a
majority of people
would be interested in owning this for
example
if you showed that nba top shop card to
someone
and you're like yeah there's only like
150 of these and like i have it
someone may look at that and go that is
so [ __ ] dope i'm actually compelled
to want to own that
you know what how much does it cost wow
that's interesting
i would be willing to pay that much
because i think that's cool
i just you know this to me feels like
all right
15 year olds figure out how to use your
mom's credit card to like
buy ethereum and then you know buy one
of these cards
yeah no i yeah i agree with you i don't
know maybe we're wrong but
it looks to be clear this isn't the art
it's a thumbnail where he's holding the
card you get but the problem is like
original whatever company he used to do
this with like on the original
marketplace website
this was the art you see on openc this
is the art you see so like
for all intents and purposes this is the
art that you're buying
it's not the ones he's holding like on
every marketplace it shows this
yeah well even
even him illustrated as pikachu just
doesn't
that doesn't sound like it's worth two
thousand dollars to me
some some unique you know
image of michael jordan you know dunking
on somebody
that makes sense to like pay two grand
for you know
even what you're talking about nba top
shop what what if they're taking like
you know not previously aired angles of
certain moments
in in sports that are like really
important to people and you can own
like this one angle and if you pay for
it you have like the full res version of
it it's like that's cool
you know yeah logan paul is still
looking let's go
let's compare this to yeah let's compare
this to other ones that are like
really popular right now the first one
that we have is crypto punks
so this is yeah so these are all this is
like one of the first nft projects
it's like it's crazy you know pixel art
basically of different faces
and they're all selling for like 50k one
sold for like
a million bucks or something like that
and what do they start out uh
yeah they were i think they were free
you could just claim them in the
beginning
so it's like and now they're working on
and every day they're selling
hold on one second we're just gonna do a
computer guy thing real fast
okay so yeah in the past in the past
24 hours one of these crypto punks that
looks like a zombie sold for
hundred and twelve thousand dollars and
then
another one sold for 125 000 another one
sold for 125 000.
but to me i understand this a little bit
more because
it's like there's each one is unique
right they're building out this like
character if you like the art style
then you know every each one is like
a little bit different than the other
one and it feels like more of like a
community like a world they're building
that but i also think like you're kind
of i think with
something like this you're like actually
buying into crypto like
this is one of the first nft projects
you know you're like supporting
something that uh you know in its own
way like
uh crypto has its own culture so
something like this
it might be cool to people who are
involved in crypto all the way back
whenever they started and they're like
oh yeah this dude is like using
blockchain tech to kind of
you know um capture
culture and and document it and you know
like you know provide art and all that
and and so
people wanting to trade this i see this
more as what nft is supposed to be used
for where people are
engaging in like virtual assets and
virtual currency and blah blah blah or
digital whatever
um and the other part that's crazy about
these prices
is these seem insane but this is just
because
there's a whole bunch of people that got
rich off of crypto and like they can
trade at these levels which is like
really crazy to think about
i know you know like these numbers
i think something like this is worth a
million dollars like i don't think that
but clearly it is because they're
[ __ ] selling for a million bucks
i mean the same way that you know you
could take what i just said about
logan paul's pikachu and say i don't get
how you know
one of these characters is worth a
million dollars i just think it's
you can it's a little bit easier to make
a case for something like this just
marginally
that this is something that appeals to a
lot of people
you know and if you blew up and created
i think because this
this also demonstrates like a lot of the
qualities of real-life collectibles yes
where like the little
like teddy bear statues or whatever
there's a [ __ ] ton of them or
build-a-bears or whatever the [ __ ]
there's a ton of them
i don't know who collects billboards
babies t-what beanie babies yeah yeah
there's like a ton of them they're all
subtly a little bit different or
obviously
different but they all live in the same
world and you build
this environment where if you're
investing in this you then you're
involved in the whole crypto uh punks
world
and then it's like you learn about this
certain hat or the certain cigarette
that one's smoking or whatever
that's what's cool about collectibles
and real life collectibles
the logan paul thing was just like
here's a 2 000 of the same thing who
knows if we'll ever do this again
yeah yeah yeah that's not really
hundred percent what else do i say
that's why i don't say it's a little
scammy i think it's big scammy
yeah gaming bro bruh
what were the other like worst of nfts
that we have
pepe oh yeah i was looking at that one
today oh yeah this there's william
shatner cards
and there's like uh like meme cards
basically
but again like both of these
what is this pepe.hero wally's street
regrets